how many relationships have you guys
ended and why
[Music]
I've only been in one so and it's not
ended so zero
three three three and why'd you end them
um it just wasn't good towards me all
violent
oh violent you did it three Violent Men
yeah stupid Please
first time it's okay like you wonder
like yeah okay it happens to anyone
second time I should have seen the red
flags but I didn't and now the third
time I just feel like I need to write
muggle my forehead do you know men that
aren't violent no I do I know a lot of
men which are my friends it just makes
no sense I just go for the ones that
they show they're nice at first and then
it's like once they grab hold of me
[Music]
they don't want me to go so they'll do
anything in any type of force I.E and
you saw no red flags at the beginning
a couple two of them yes uh one of them
no I just like Wonder because if I was a
guy listening to this I'd be like why
would I be nice to you because you don't
like like you know the nice guys but you
don't pick them and you just keep um if
anything like it would incentivize them
to be abusive she does the thing I think
like
normally like I would feel like a guy
would come to me thinking oh she's been
in free relationships that have just
been violent but I've actually had
nothing but good guys to come towards me
since I just I've been taking my time
whether I want to be in a relationship
with someone or not because I really
don't want to go to a fourth time and
that's it I will be getting mug tattooed
on my forehead yeah
um what about you
you're only 19. yeah
um have I ended a religion I have ended
one
um and I think I ended it just because I
think I just wasn't I wasn't ready for
the commitment
um yeah
fickle
I think I just wasn't ready I think it
was kind of like
I was just like yeah and uh and it kind
of just shut me off completely like
after that it was kind of like I don't
know why I did it nothing it's just
completely cut off and it was like I
didn't feel the same way anymore
and that was literally the end of it
there's no more to that than it than I'm
saying but yeah
I think we you said you had two
relationships and you ended one no no no
they ended both I'm more of a stay in a
relationship make it work kind of person
then jump off and give up
by having said that the first person
wasn't a great person so once he left
and he had made that choice it was taken
away from me so then I could then go and
be happy so I was actually grateful that
he ended it and that's why I didn't let
him come back I actually understand that
thinking because when it's like if they
break up with you you don't really have
a choice in it so you don't have to like
guess if it was the right choice because
it wasn't your choice yeah it's easier
to detach when someone else breaks up
with you than it is to for you to break
up with them do you think women ever try
to get guys to break up with them yeah
100 yeah oh they do everything I feel
like that happens all the time I feel
like if you're in a relationship but you
just feel like it's kind of like he's
sometimes maybe a bit more committed but
maybe not in the way that you want it to
be you're probably going to do
everything in your power for him to be
like yeah I'm not trying like you're
doing Madness whereas that's not
actually you but it's kind of like
you're provoking that because it's just
like you don't it's kind of like you see
it but then at the same time you don't
and it's like it's easier like I can't
cool it off because he has valid points
so therefore I'm going to provoke
whatever situation it is to make him
break up with me so that I can just be
like cool you broke up with me and I'll
leave it as it is and just let them case
rest uh yeah I just want to jump off
something that you said a moment ago
where um a lot of times say if you get
broken up with it's easier for you to
move on
um I kind of think with women it's the
opposite because when we break up with
someone we break up with them with them
in our head and then you know six weeks
later then we break up with them so I
thought perhaps it'd be a little easier
if we leave someone because often we've
planned it you know for a lot of women
there's a guy already waiting
um whereas if you get broken up with
especially if you think things are going
fine it's this you know complete change
of circumstances sprung upon you so I
thought perhaps that would make it a
little worse actually yeah you're
probably right actually now that I'm
thinking about it because if things were
going well like that probably would
devastate me yeah but it's like yeah
yeah but it's kind of like if you're
fighting already you know if you're
fighting already you've probably
mentally checked out as well you just
wait for one or the other person to do
it I actually do agree with you yeah
that's never happened when it was like
like it was you know
do you think that women detach quicker
than men
depends on a woman
I feel like okay
I feel like women detach quicker than
men most of the time like if she has 10
relationships like eight or nine of them
but there's like one guy that like she
cannot detach from okay like like and I
use it because you can see it in pop
culture like a lot of 100 a lot of the
movies that like women love like Titanic
The Notebook what is it what is it about
about that guy it's like the lady in the
Titanic is like 90 talking about her
High School fling yeah and she's still
talking about that and same with the
notebook it's her going back to that guy
from high school yeah so I feel like
unless it's like that guy like women
typically get over it easier than Matt
but if you're like that guy to her then
she doesn't
um I thought the reason why I say women
get over men quickly is because I think
we're aware more of an emotional we're
going through more of an emotional time
than men are
um I feel like you're in certain
situations where if something happens
it's kind of like you feel it way more
than you would feel than your
significant other would feel and then
yeah fair enough no I thought so I'm I'm
talking more from my experience is what
I'm trying to say I feel like there's
I'm a very emotional person if something
happens
um my emotions is in it 100 and it's
kind of like if something keeps
happening I'll kind of I'll kind of get
used to it and I'll kind of be like
whoever so if so if you're involved in a
relationship where like things will keep
constantly happening they'll get to a
point you like you'll actually get to a
point where you're kind of like yeah
like you could do something and I just
completely like I won't react the same
way anymore and it kind of just you like
the relationship will end and you kind
of just like cool whatever because you
already felt what you needed to felt
during the relationship so why she's not
going through heartbreak after I think
women just underestimate men's emotions
yeah I think women are just out there
crying and blubbering and whatever and
the men just take it because if they're
to turn around and cry and blubber I
mean if you're the man and yeah there
must be a minute square with men and
they just start crying what did you
think about them lose total respect for
them yeah that's why they don't do it
they just deal with it but women got
them blah all their friends will come
around and always done this so he's done
that and man they're trying to travel
so you're telling me women lose respect
for men that core would cry to you oh my
God yeah of course I swear you wanna
okay you want a guy leading you
imagine the CEO of a company just crying
in front of his employees it's the same
thing with the relationship you're not
going to respect a guy's leadership the
same way if he's crying all the time can
I ask because I never cried in front of
you I'm I've had people be emotional
towards me and it hasn't made me lose
respect for you because I feel like a
fair both like establish that type of
relationship you can't cry to me I'll
look at you like cool let me put it this
way right you use with a man and you
tell him you don't want to be with him
anymore and he starts crying and
blubbering what would you do how would
you feel that's kind of different that's
what we mean that's what we're talking
about even my pride wouldn't let me cry
for someone if they broke up with me
I thought you said that you that women
cry and get emotional when they get when
they were split up with a man
pardon I thought you said that women
crying they get emotional when they
split up with a man I mean they do right
so I'm saying turning on it said what if
it was a man that's better with a woman
and he's the one that's blubbering
I mean cool cool like if you're crying
then you care didn't it like I don't I
don't know what you actually want me to
do how would you feel towards him do you
think it'd make you want to get back
with him in any like would you be more
attracted to him or less attracted to
him
it depends on who it is yeah if he yeah
it depends on who it is if you look ugly
crying though sorry
about but yeah it actually depends who
it is like 100 but I think that girls
usually and I can say this from having
not from my own experience but from
friends who go through this uh one of
our friends
um said to me when we're on first time
um that she had an argument with her
boyfriend
um and essentially she did it just to
see if he would like kind of chase after
him FaceTime or uncaller and you know lo
and behold 50 no caller ID calls and she
said to me well like I don't really want
him to be doing that like I want to go
after him and I thought it was quite
strange because you know you'd think
that you'd want someone to come after
you and you know chase after but
typically you know women are attracted
unfortunately to toxicity so
um yeah but is it not toxic to be
harassing someone like that of course
that's of course that's toxic
um but I'm saying in terms of
in terms of the relationship
um a lot of time
how to explain it
um it's toxic to be harassing someone
and but it's also you know toxic to
leave someone that you love with no
final word which is what she would see
that relationship as but for some reason
that's what she would gravitate more to
than someone that's trying to get her
back yeah that's what that's what I
meant I'm a cut and go you lie to me I'm
gone you cheat I'm gone
[Laughter]
but I had to go confide another woman to
make me realize that you're the one I'm
looking for I'm gonna keep on going and
then keep on thinking
no if you lied to me from the beginning
you have to set the rules down from the
beginning and if I have a man you know
don't lie to me don't you if you lie
it's over if you cheat it's over I don't
care why it's over finishing no
conversation is done because women is
like oh you know if he cheats on me you
know and then what he's going to do
again he's going to do again he's gonna
do it again if I told you once it's gone
it's finished it's gone and if you cry
it's even worse and you're even stupid
to believe him if he says he's never
gonna do it again but what if he doesn't
do it men most probably wouldn't but
that's my line my line is like no
no I've seen it happen too many times
girl goes back cheats some more I would
rather just not look like a clown what
would you say most girls go back after
they get cheated on some not all what
percent how many friends do you know
that I've gotten cheated on
a couple but it was the situation that
they had been in so they say if it
involved kids obviously they want to put
the kids first you know I mean um no I
know there's reasons I'm just curious
yeah but I don't think I think after
they've been cheated on once they start
where I'm such a
type of person I am and the way I handle
things obviously the people around me
they've done dumb stupid things like
I've done stupid things in the past
but I just feel like how many how many
friends of yours have gotten cheated on
a couple so so two three yeah three
three and how many stayed with him after
he cheated
um two two but they've not they're not
with them anymore right I just meant
like when they cheated they stayed yeah
they stayed with them afterwards but
then they left flat obviously yeah yeah
later yeah as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible